good morning my name is Josh gardener
and I'm a senior history major before I
introduce today's speaker I've been
asked to Mikey the next week's
communication will be Wayne Smith
visiting professor of Latin American
Studies at Johns Hopkins University he
will be speaking on relations between
the United States and Cuba the feminist
and anarchist Emma Goldman once said
they quote history may be a compilation
of lies nevertheless contains a few
truths and they're the only guides we
have the future today's speaker Howard
Zinn has dedicated his life to writing
the lives of history and employing those
lessons to build a better future he is a
noted historian a gifted playwright and
a passionate political activist most of
us know mr. Zinn is the author of that
book a people's history of the United
States which are high school social
studies teacher assign is a contrast to
the traditional text in fact the work
was wildly successful it helped to usher
in a whole new approach to American
history since heroes are not Columbus
capitalists or presidents but Native
Americans industrial workers and all
those who have risked everything to
combat tyranny and oppression believing
it impossible to separate the study of
history from one's inner convictions and
sense of justice mr. Zinn is also a
tireless social crusader through the
years this marriage of scholarship and
activism has alternatively found him
writing articles attacking the Kennedy
administration for its inaction with
segregation and helping to organize
student students writing a book entitled
the Vietnam the logic of withdrawal and
speaking out against the Vietnam War at
peace protests and like most good
Americans his belief in action is landed
him in jail a couple of times along the
way this fall I've read mr. Zane's most
recent work you can't be neutral and
moving train a personal history of our
times and I must say that is his
optimism and faith in the capacity
American people to enact social change
is truly inspiring it it is a must read
while disillusioned college students or
anyone anxious about the direction our
nation is taking I'm very excited about
today's presentation please join me in
welcoming Howard Zinn to Carleton
College
well thanks thanks for inviting me to
Carleton this is a special place
well one thing you have Marv Davidoff
teaching here I think I think it's a
tribute to Carleton that you would have
mark Davidoff come here and teach and
without asking him how many phd's do you
have the only question maybe was what
have you done with your life
and what have you done on behalf of
peace and justice and you've been doing
that only to life maybe you have
something to say to our students so and
I learned last night that students had
called in college have been working with
people in the community to do something
about the welfare situation and
Minnesota and in a nation and to me
that's that's the best sign of where the
students are getting an education
because one of the things I learned by
going to college and by being out of
college is you're very open to know we
learn a lot more by leaving the
classroom and getting involved in social
activism and then when you come back to
the classroom that everything you study
means so much more to you so yeah I'm
glad to be here I have I have about 40
minutes and I going to try in 40 minutes
to tell you what I've learned in 40
years just time to save you some time
and well I promised I would talk about
history and sometimes I keep my promise
and I suppose I got into history of
teaching and writing history not just
because it was interesting it is
interesting it's fun
it's sort of that investigative things
you read people's private letters you
read secret government documents you
read things that the government doesn't
want you to know and yeah so it's
interesting but it's it's much more than
that
I think I really got into history not
just because it's interesting I didn't
want to just be one of those historians
who who goes into the past and and gets
lost and never comes out you know I
wanted to go into the past and and come
out and and see what I could find out
from the past that would be useful and
what is happening in the world today and
because I came to the conclusion of
history is a kind of life and death
matter
I read George Orwell and probably you
know some of George Orwell's works in
1984 won Animal Farm
maybe his lesser-known but very very
remarkable book homage to Catalonia but
in in 1984 at one point he he says talks
about the control of history he says
whoever controls the past controls the
future and whoever controls the present
controls the past so that those people
who control what we know today that is
the mass media the government the
educational system the textbook
publishers the people who control what
we know today
determining our future unless we break
away from that and unless we get to
learn things for ourselves there's
nothing more important than education
and breaking away from the authorities
breaking away from the books that are
given you from the things they've told
you from the television broadcasts that
are aimed at you and just going out and
looking for yourself looking in the dark
corners of the libraries picking up the
things that are handed out on street
corners really just getting information
if you can't get anywhere else and so I
I decided history was important you can
tell the importance of history but by
how much controversy is raised when
people start to write or speak a
different kind of history they notice
how much excitement has been I almost
use the word hysteria about the new
history as but the the reteaching of
Columbus or the new view of the bombing
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki or an
expansion of the curriculum to go beyond
the usual tributes to Western
civilization and to talk about the third
world and non-western civilizations and
those people who've been humiliated by
Western civilization
notice how when I say excited when I say
hysterical I thought I'm not
exaggerating too much I mean people they
will say things like
George will they will say things like
George will that's that that's that is
real hysteria nothing can make one
angrier but George will talked about the
disagreements over curriculum which you
think is a mild affair I mean a
disagreement over curricula that's the
stuff of boring back of the names no
disagreements of the curriculum he said
is a part of a war a war of aggression
against the Western political tradition
a war of aggression and Hilton Kramer
longest eight line said it is our
civilization that we believe to be at
stake in this struggle I mean would
think we were talking about World War
two and d-day you know a civilization is
at stake Ihnen and somebody from the
National Association of scholars which
is a a euphemism for an organization of
right-wing writers and says about the
new history the barbarians are in our
midst I winced when I read that because
I felt he was talking about me
but the reason there's all this
excitement about the new history is that
it's not just about the past it's not
it's not about straightening the record
just so that we will know what happened
in the past more accurately because
everything about the past is about the
present and the future
the the the excitement over Columbus and
the changing of the Columbus story is
there because it has all sorts of
meaning for today because when you start
to to reconsider Columbus always looked
upon as a hero but generation after
generation after generation that's
interesting isn't it here is a liberal
democratic country a marketplace of
ideas etcetera etcetera one story was
told about Columbus the generation after
generation after generation Columbus the
hero Columbus the adventurer Columbus
the brave man Columbus the Bible reader
I mean what could be better the
religious man and you wonder we know
that's too totalitarian countries they
just get one view of history but we were
a democratic country how come is it
possible that we have a control of
information that is more subtle more
insidious but just as clear as the
control of information takes place in
what we call totalitarian countries but
as a reason for this and that is
Columbus represents Western civilization
at its worst oh there is Western
civilization at its best you know and
there are nice things you can say about
Western civilization by the advancements
in technology and and medicine science
and education yes there they're positive
things you can say about Western
civilization at its best but there's
also Western civilization at its worst
and that's what Columbus represents and
by that I mean aggression
expansion the enslavement of other
peoples the assignment to other peoples
of a status less than the human being
which is what Columbus assigned to the
Indian city that he found on Hispaniola
enabling him to enslave them and kidnap
them and torture them and kill them that
was omitted the generation after
generation because it it raises too many
questions about the human costs of what
is called progress in Western
civilization
raises too many questions about greed
because after all Columbus came here not
to convert the Indians to Christianity
although he talked about that but he
came here for gold and then and to to
honor that to honor the the killing and
kidnapping of other people for profit
something has been going on for too long
had to question that is the question
capitalism really I think there's a
connection I know this is hard to take
maybe because we all love capitalism we
have to we're in the midst of it it
surrounds us right we must love it you
see and to suggest that there's some
connection between capitalism and
ruthless greed is troubling
I remember reading a description of
capitalism as the adjectives use was
savage unbridled capitalism and then I
looked to see who said that I thought
well obviously some communist it was
John Pope John Paul say which made me
worry a little about him and
and I wouldn't be surprised that after
he said that he said that in an
interview with an Italian journalist I
wouldn't be surprised after that he had
ended up on the FBI's list I can just
see see the FBI people filing through
their photos oh there's the Pope
savage unbridled capitalism yeah so the
Columbus story is a story of not about
yesterday but I thought today and the
rethinking of the bombing of Hiroshima
is not just a question of correcting the
record of what happened in August of
1945 it's a question of asking about the
bombs that we are stockpiling and have
been stockpiling ever since world war ii
asking why we a Soviet Union and
whatever other countries are carrying
nuclear weapons why we've been ready to
do the same thing as was done in
Hiroshima Nagasaki only to do it many
times over and ask whether we are still
in the psychology in whether our leaders
are still trying to keep us in a
psychology of justifying the large-scale
killing of people just so long it's for
a good reason
governments when they killed in large
numbers they always do so for a good
reason and that's what we must be on
guard against so these are these are not
past issues these are present present
issues things that we tell us that we
study history because we want to
understand something about our time so
you may get the idea that in my in my
views of history I have not been neutral
I've never considered myself a neutral
teacher I always start my classes off by
telling students right off I said this
is not going to be a neutral class I
would say you can't be neutral on a
moving train put another way the world
is already going in certain directions
certain terrible directions wars are
taking place people are getting killed
landmines are
children are going hungry in a world
like this to be neutral in anything you
do is to collaborate with whatever is
going on and I never want it to be a
collaborator and so I saw teaching and I
saw writing as something that could not
possibly be neutral and that had to take
a stand and then one of my students to
know it I wanted them to feel free to
take their stands and then let us have
an honest discussion about all all of
the issues in the world so so I studied
history because I cared about about what
was going on in the world and I never
believed in what they call objectivity
unless objectivity means not
deliberately lying not distorting not
concealing information that it goes
against what you've declared yourself
for but if objectivity means a
pretending that you don't have a view
about what was going on in the world of
what has happened in the world well I
know I never believed that objectivity
was possible and I know leaders
desirable and I believed it was possible
because in doing history and writing
history and teaching history
you're always selecting out of an
enormous body of data and it can only be
a very very tiny selection out of that
great body of information inevitably and
what you select for as in most cases
what is selected for you by whoever
produces the textbooks well whoever
prints the newspapers or whoever gives
you the news
at eleven o'clock whatever is selected
for you is dependent on the viewpoint of
the selector and so I understood that
there could be no such thing as an
objective presentation of the facts of
the past that selection always depended
on the point of view of the selector and
that the most important question you
could ask about anything any set of
historical facts presented to you is not
so much is this a false factors as a
true fact the most important question
you can ask is what has been left out
what hasn't been told me just as things
were they didn't lie about Columbus when
they said he was a brave man and a
religious man no they just omitted
things they didn't lie about Hiroshima
when they said yes the war ended right
after the bombing of Hiroshima and and
the Japanese will cruel in the war and
so on but they left out things as they
left out the messages and with that and
I saw this last in year in 1995 when
they with all the discussion about
Hiroshima and with all the press talking
about Hiroshima but I didn't see the the
information that historians and other
people who study the subject know about
that the telegrams that went back and
forth from the Japanese diplomats to
their emissary in Moscow trying to
negotiate in an end to the war telegram
Talitha intercepted by American
intelligence so that they knew about
which indicated the Japanese one the
verge of surrender that the bombs did
not have to be dropped we didn't have to
kill all those people the withholding of
information the omission of information
that that was to look for that is the
most important lesson one can learn in
how to
how to read excuse me um how to listen
when you give it information especially
by like people in authority and and when
the government gives you information
always asks what have they left out the
government and not long ago p-- the few
years ago there's a scholar who resigned
from a government commission and better
than by advise the State Department on
its production of volumes on Foreign
Relations to the United States he
resigned because the United States
government insisted on holding to its
its rule that it could not print
information documents of American
foreign policy unless they were at least
30 years old that is good it could not
talk about anything that happened within
the last 30 years but he said it went
even further they even when they
produced volumes on events that happened
more than 30 years ago they were lying
about it they were distorting me he was
signed because he saw the volumes they
were producing about 1952 53 54 they
said the government has distorted and
left out information about what we did
in Iran and overthrowing that government
what we did in Guatemala and
overthrowing that government what we did
in Southeast Asia in helping the French
to maintain colonial control of over
Indochina and so he resigned his job so
you know government documents have to be
inspected very closely and the question
asked what have they left out the great
journalist if' stone when if you don't
know who he is find out it's one of the
one of the one of the great journalists
in American history and he when he would
speak to classes of journalism students
he was
say some of the best advice I could give
you as people who are going to be
journalists can be summed up in two
words governments lie so I was always
interested in what was being omitted
omitted in the mass media omitted in
government documents and omitted in in
the history textbooks one of the many
things that was omitted in in the books
it occurred to me at a certain point was
the class nature of American society
class is something that is that we don't
like to talk about in the United States
we don't use words like class
consciousness and class struggle and
class conflict I remember doing that if
you can remember way back to the camp
presidential campaign of bush in Dukakis
try to remember what an exciting to
imagine what an exciting campaign and
bush to Giants and Bush Bush appears
Dukakis of appealing to class conflict
which is really surprised me there's me
I was from Massachusetts Dukakis had
been the governor of Massachusetts could
not imagine Dukakis getting excited
about class or getting excited about
anything
so class is something we don't like to
talk about that in fact the history of
the United States has a history of class
conflict from a very good we've had
class from the beginning we didn't all
come here as pilgrims I remember that
was the impression I had and after going
to school everybody came here and they
dressed like those people with those
funny clothes you know and and we were
all equal and somehow some people ended
up very rich and other people ended up
or did that happen you know I guess some
people must have worked much harder you
know like a million times harder but
then you know reading a little bit of
colonial history learn no we didn't come
here at equal some people came here with
enormous land grants of land given to
them by the crowd huge
hundreds of thousands of acres of land
and other people came here with nothing
because black people came here with less
than nothing and they came back here as
slaves and white people came as
indentured servants and others came with
no property and from the very beginning
off of our history in the seventeenth
century
we were already rich and poor we were
only people with wealth and power and
and other people with with nothing when
there when the Constitution was drawn up
it was a recognition of that I mean the
people who drew up when when Madison was
arguing for the adoption of the
Constitution one of the reasons he gave
was now look you know there are people
with property and people without
property and there's gonna be trouble
I'm paraphrasing Madison
he he really he wrote so elegantly and I
you know I've always tried to recapture
you know that 18th century style but it
hasn't worked I think I'm up to it
I've gotten back to the 19th century but
not far enough but Madison its we've got
to worry about the country factions life
actually met classes well you see Marx
hadn't been born yet and but he taught
with actions properly no property and
how you need needed to have this new
government this new constitution this
strong central government in order to to
keep the peace in order to make sure as
he put it that there would not be a rage
for paper money which poor farmers
wanted not to pay off their debts or for
an equal division of property or as he
put it these were his exact words for
any other improper or wicked object and
so yeah the Constitution was a class
document when I first read Charles
beards and economic interpretation the
Constitution a book which has the
distinction of being one of the few
books ever written by historians which
which excited an editorial from the New
York Times denouncing it the beer talked
about the class interests of the
founding fathers you probably know the
founding fathers were not a
multicultural group
they were 55 rich white men maybe one or
two of them could be classified as not
so rich as the others but and the
Constitution set up a government that
would set benefit the interests of that
class represented by those 55 men it's
interesting because today you hear talk
about big government the government is
bad Clinton said writing in the courses
of a young campaign the era of big
government is over and everybody
Republicans Democrats and the media and
they repeat again and again you know big
government is bad big military isn't bad
military is not the government I guess
big if there are big things that are not
bad that the government do it and there
are other things Medicare that's bad but
if we have a national health program run
by the government the way they have in
other countries which work very well if
which give the health care free to
everybody that would be big government
the Constitution set up big government
there set up big government on behalf of
the upper classes it's set up of
governmental bodies strong enough to
protect the interests of the bondholders
take off their bonds you could find an
unbroken thread running from the
founding fathers down to the federal
reserve system of today in government
legislation to protect the bondholders
the business a strong government was set
up by the Constitution to protect the
bondholders to protect slave owners
against slave revolts to protect land
speculators who are going out west to
protect them against Indian attacks
Indians seem to think
their land to protect manufacturers by
tariffs and that's that the history of
legislation in this country has been
history of class legislation of
government of legislation on behalf of
the rich and powerful in this country
right from the Hamiltons first economic
message to Congress right through right
through the the 19th century when the
government was giving huge subsidies to
the railroads 20 million of acres of
land given free to the railroads by the
states and in 1850s a hundred million
acres of land given free to the
railroads by the federal government
during the Civil War they don't when
they give us histories of the Civil War
they tell us excitedly about the battles
of Gettysburg in the battles of Antietam
in the battles of Fredericksburg and
they don't tell us much about that 100
million acres of free land I would call
that welfare on a very large scale we
try getting an acre of land from the
government just write a letter to your
Congressman say I would like I'm not
asking much but I've been reading about
the Union Pacific Railroad and I would
like one acre it's
it's for my family I believe in family
values this is the subsidies continued
well all through the subsidy higher and
higher tariffs to protect the
manufacturers you know subsidies in
World War two the aircraft industry in
the United States would have collapsed
if not for the government supplied 92
percent of the capital for the aircraft
industry in World War two billions of
dollars and at the end of World War two
when we know we didn't need the war
planes anymore you could argue before
that what we needed it for the war after
the war the government continued to
subsidize the aircraft industry which
would have gone out of business if not
for government subsidies and you can
read the memoranda that went back and
forth between assistant secretary of the
air Stuart Symington and the heads of
Lockheed and the other aircraft
companies in which Simonton says don't
worry
fellows that's also a paraphrase
well maybe sends that quote don't worry
guys we'll take care of you and he said
in one of his letters he said we let's
not call it subsidies let's call it
security well I think wealthy I'm
letters around the country should say
we're not asking for welfare we're just
asking for security that's all
so anyway the the the whole history of a
remember the history that I learned in
high school is a history of the Greek
wonders of the Industrial Revolution you
know how great it was that the railroads
went across the continent and steel
mills went up the United States became
the number one economic power in the
world but I didn't learn and this was
omitted from I didn't learn about the
human cost of what was called progress
of industrialization of the improvement
of technology I didn't learn about the
girls who went to work in the textile
mills of New England at the age of 12
and died at the age of 25 didn't learn
about the Irish and Chinese immigrants
who worked on the railroads and like
20,000 of them on the Union Pacific
Railroad in the heat and the cold 16
hours a day and died of sickness and
overwork and didn't learn about that
instead we got things like oh these were
the gay nineties how gay well I would
question the word gay when it comes down
well all people like that in the 90s
were people happy in the 90s it was the
gate the Roaring Twenties the Jazz Age
you the age of prosperity I mean right
up through graduate school I was getting
the same designations for these periods
and you had to look behind these these
overall as statements about a period see
what but how about what marry people
living in those how ordinary people
living in the game 90s what about the
kids
the children who in Philadelphia who
died by the thousands in the 90s and the
depression of 1893 that they were
drinking polluted water from the river
while the rich had clean water water is
a class phenomenon just as fire as a
class phenomenon the people who die in
fires are the people who live in in
those
little that houses that are susceptible
to fire or who have to use a heating
equipment you know that can explode and
so on so all this all this a minute and
today we are expected to estimate the
state of our society in the state of our
economy and the prosperity of our people
how by looking at these overall
statements made the economy is up have
the figures are given to us which are so
the aggregate to figures you know
unemployment has gone down the I just
saw figure in just the other day the
average income of Americans has risen
you average Donald Trump and you know a
factory worker and the average has
definitely gone up so the Dow Jones
average every night every night without
fail the Dow Jones average and we're
supposed to after we get that night
after night begin to believe that the
Dow Jones average is an accurate
reflection of how people are living in
this country the Dow Jones average has
gone up I feel wonderful
don't try that next time yeah you're in
a restaurant tell the waitress have you
heard that the dow jones average has
gone up
I'm sure you'll get much better service
you cheer your waitress up with that
news and so we we get these what Kurt
Vonnegut called grandfa loons these the
great big balloons which which encompass
a situation and which leave you ignorant
of all the details of how of people
people are living and and and so it's
possible to believe that we are living
well if you just pay attention to the
Dow Jones average or if you just stay in
one part of the city and if you don't
venture into another part of the city
but you have to in every city in this
country if you go from one end of the
city to the other end of the city you
will see what a class society we live in
and you will see the people in New York
and Chicago and Cleveland in Detroit and
Boston and see the people who live in
very nice houses in one part of the city
and who people who live like a third
world people in the slums of Brazil in
another part of the city and so in when
President Clinton gets on the air and as
an organ talks in such glowing terms
about how wonderful everything is and
this inflation has gone down and income
has gone up and unemployment so on
well serious questions need to be asked
what did he'll meant he seems to have
admitted the fact that that every year
in this country
40,000 children die before they are one
year old that the in infant mortality
the United States ranks 20th among 20
industrialized countries in the matter
of dealing with infant mortality that
there are parts of American cities where
the rate of children dying of infants
dying is like the rate in Bangladesh or
or Guatemala and these are the things
you know
mitad in these very romantic
descriptions of how well we are doing
and as possible as possible to live in
the United States because we are a very
rich country and we have many many signs
of wealth we do have a big middle class
even though that middle class is very
nervous but we do have all the signs
when it's possible to not to pay any
attention to the 30 or 40 million people
who don't have health insurance and to
the kids who are dying and by the way
all those are those kids who are who are
dying half of them are black and 13% of
the black of the population is black but
fifty percent of the kids who die before
they are when you're older black class
and race intersect poverty and race
intersect again and again so I would
suggest that we need to think about not
just that but how things have been
omitted about but other issues than
class about war about race when things
are omitted and when you don't know any
history it's as if you were born
yesterday and and anything can be told
to you because if you were born
yesterday the president can get on
television and say something has
happened in this part of the world we
must go over there and bomb for freedom
and you have no way of checking up
you have no history to check up on this
you don't know if you don't know any
history how many times heads of states
have gone to microphones and ask the
young people of this country to give up
their lives and to cause other people
and other countries to give up their
lives this is something that they that
the government has designated as a war
for freedom offer liberation or for
democracy or to as to end all wars
I think they've even stopped saying that
they've given up on and they all war
who's there preparing as they say to
fight wars again right that's what law I
was spending two hundred fifty billion
dollars for the military because we have
to be prepared for as they say the
number changes from time time with
praying for one and a half Wars or two
wars while one major war and one
regional war one major war and two
regional force right but we're preparing
for war
well little history would make you
suspicious especially the young people I
understand are high school students here
from Southwest High School and in the
Twin Cities and I think I think of high
school students is being the most
vulnerable because they will graduate
from high school and at some point some
head of government will say it's time
for you to die for your country for
freedom for democracy and so on history
will come in very handy at that point
and we
black people Native Americans take a
different view of our history than the
rest of the population when I was
teaching in the South teaching in a
black woman's college in Atlanta for
seven years and during the years of the
civil rights movement becoming involved
in the movement and beginning to read
the work of black historians I began to
see American history from a different
point of view
when I began investigating the Columbus
story and and then what what we what we
did in rampaging across this country and
annihilating Indian tribes again and
again so we could have this territory
gave me a different view of American
history try to read a history of a civil
war in which they tell you that during
the Civil War when the me anticipation
Proclamation was was being put forth and
we're fighting a war for freedom and so
on
how many history books will tell you
that during the Civil War the United
States Army moving out west took more
land on the Indians that had any
comparable period in American history so
so yes
history is useful so if you look know
for what has been omitted and what I
won't try to finish up I'm looking at my
watch to pretend that I care
but by well one of the things I have
learned from from both from reading
history and from participating in social
movements from the civil rights movement
and the anti-war movement and and even
coming to Minneapolis to protest against
the production of landmines and only
thing one of the things I've learned
from that kind of experience is if we're
going to change things if we're going to
become more conscious of how what is
happening to people in the rest of the
world as a result of our policies I
heard one one a friend of mine once said
when he was asked to be in critical
display why didn't you move to another
country he said well I'm not gonna move
to another country because then they'll
become a victim of our foreign policy
I say but how does change come about how
are we gonna do anything about all of
this no I mean one one thing is clear
real change is not gonna happen in this
country as a result of voting I'm sorry
to say that because I know we've all
brought up on this huh we're taught you
know this is democracy this you know
democracy the highest act of citizenship
is to go to the polls every two years of
four years and pull down that little
lever you've done your job
I can go home and we'll take care of the
rest
and they do say the voting historically
voting has not made any major changes
and I saw a bumper sticker not long ago
which said if the gods had intended us
to vote they would have given us
candidates
well as a matter of fact that I don't
think that God's would be in a position
to give us candidates because they
probably don't have enough money you see
you need money to get into the electoral
process you know and Jesus or Moses or
Buddha or Mohammed who showed up at the
White House
you know without money they would not be
allowed in right they would need two
hundred thousand dollars to have dinner
with Clinton well with if it was a
Republican president they would need
three hundred thousand dollars she say
that's a difference between Republicans
and Democrats it's enormous difference
the change is taking place in this
country when people have gotten together
when citizens have organized
I mean slavery was not done away with by
a link Kony and edik slavery was done
away with by the growth of a great
anti-slavery movement in his [ __ ] a
black and white abolitionist who put
pressure on Lincoln again and again
again and on Congress until finally they
began to act and then they had to do it
again in the 1960s when again Kennedy
Johnson we're not quite to act until
black people took to the streets and
went to prison and were beaten and were
killed and citizens got together
organized and took risks and only then
was racial segregation done away with in
the south the labor movement the
eight-hour day was not won by the
kindness of employers deciding to give
the eight-hour day or by the initiative
of government not at all the eight-hour
day was won by workers in the 19th
century in 20th century going out on
strike facing gun the National Guard and
the army and struggling and changing the
conditions of their life and women did
not get to the point of this this new
feminist consciousness that we have
today of because of any government
initiatives they did it on their own and
disabled people did not win the right to
to wheelchair access so it have the
streets change so they could move around
they did not get this because Congress
or the president because somebody who's
just elected
did anything about it no the the the
channels of government that they always
tell us to use you go through channels
they're not channels there mazes into
which we are invited to get lost and so
that what we've learned historically is
the week you don't go through the
channels won't do it the channels will
only begin to work when citizens
organize and create a commotion garrison
the abolitionist said to somebody who
urged him to be more moderate he said
slavery sir will not be overthrown
without excitement a tremendous
excitement that's still true today we
need a new movement the possibilities
are there people have common sense the
Muslims mistake was silence to people
for not caring I learned that by being
in the south and sand in the late 1950s
and and seeing what seemed to be well
nobody was doing anything things will
quiet you don't know what people are
thinking you don't know what people are
feeling you don't know what indignation
is building up and people who know that
something is wrong and at a certain
point in history and you don't know
exactly when things begin to happen and
you get a social movement against the
war in Vietnam against racial
segregation for women's rights for gay
rights at certain points in history but
the only way happens is that people do
things the smallest of things things
that don't seem to go anywhere things
that don't seem to have any immediate
effect but that's how social movements
build on the basis of huge numbers of
small acts that people take and that
finally come together at some point
and if you if you do this well life will
be different it'll be better sure if you
need Economic Security and you need jobs
and you know and not everybody can be a
Marv dab it off and become a full-time
activist you must go to the movies too
sometime
but we have to do those things you have
you have to have some security but
that's not enough you don't want to be
able it won't be important that you know
your grandchildren think of you all wow
my grandfather and grandmother had three
houses
I'm so proud they say no there's a
picture of them on a picket line there's
a picture then in some struggle for
justice you know so that even if we
don't you know involved in some way in
the struggle against war against
militarism against injustice then but
life will be more interesting and more
fun thank you
all right I think I think we have a
little bit of a time for anybody to say
anything raised any questions if this
this is known as freedom of speech one
person gets 40 minutes 200 people get
three minutes anybody yes your
maintenance or wheel alignment control
the past would you uh reflect a little
bit about the recent shutdown of the
Smithsonian Institution their attempt to
give a true historical perspective of
the bombing of Japan with the atomic
bomb well yeah well there's an example
of where even the politicians you know
put the Smithsonian gets federal money
you know so much of so much of the
information we that we get is dependent
on money from rich and powerful sources
same thing with the Smithsonian and so
when a Smithsonian was going to put an
exhibit which might show some of the
things we did to the people of Japan had
victory all the congressmen and Senators
and and veterans organizations put the
pressure on and they caved in and the
result was the presentation I was there
I saw their exhibit in Washington and it
was all about well you know we were the
good guys we did the right thing we
shortened the war and you could not get
any sense at all from that exhibit of
the devastation that we caused in
Hiroshima and Nagasaki and you certainly
couldn't get any notion of the
information that is now easily available
that shows that we did not have to drop
those bombs in order to win the war
and I have sometimes said to people who
especially veterans of World War two and
I'm a veteran of World War two I was a
Bombardier and
in World War two and I was an
enthusiastic Bombardier but I came out
of it at the end of the war and I began
to question the whole notion of war
whether war ever solves anything
and and and I sometimes will say - yes
especially to people of that era who
defend the bombing of Hiroshima acts
like what we had to do in order to win
the war well look if you were told at
that time that we had to kill a hundred
thousand American children in order to
win the war would you do it really not
in order to win the war Justin just want
to speed up the winning of the war by a
few days or a few weeks or a few months
when you kill a hundred thousand
American children to do it well the
answer is clear and what does that mean
that means that Japanese children are
not equal to our children now that's
something we have desperately need to
get over the idea that the children of
other countries do not have as much of a
right to live at the children of our
country and war now kills more children
than soldiers in the wars today as
opposed to the Wars of the past the
ratio of civilians killed to military
killed is 10 to 1 that's why we must
renounce war because war is not a war
against this evil person that you're
pushing that tyrant that dictator war is
always a war against children and if all
children are equal then we must renounce
war we must take the military budget and
use it for the things we need to make a
better society
somebody else yes I noticed in your
discussion about oppression in America
excuse me
I noticed in your discussion about
oppression in America you omitted
discussions about Latino culture and
committed what discussions about Latino
culture Latino I'm sorry oh you're right
I did
that's an omission yeah oh yeah it's no
you're absolutely right
in cataloging all the sins that have
done against various peoples in our
society it's it's it's very easy to to
leave people out and and it's done son
on the basis of a insufficiently
heightened consciousness you see which I
plead to but in fact when I wrote
people's history back in the late 70s I
really didn't say much about the Latino
people in this country and about their
struggles and in my new new edition I
try to correct that night I talk more
about about the the farmworkers and the
problems of Latino workers in this
country and I mean no one can say about
it is one of the things one of the
things we get we can learn from from
that well we learned something from the
omission about our general you know how
easily easily easy it is for us to
forget the people that we don't come in
contact with every day both but from the
history of the Hispanic people we can
learn something about our the way we we
we take the people who who lived in
in the Far West before we did and
declare them persona non-grata or how we
invite the in the farm workers from
Mexico to come over when they needed to
work the farms and then declare them as
illegal immigrants and build a steel
wall across Southern California to keep
them out that this whole issue of
immigrants is something that we really
need to think about that the
classification of immigrants legal or
illegal I mean the very idea note that
that this should they should be this
this kind of distinction Oh born here
not one year of Clinton and his
inaugural address well we must remedy
this situation that we we are denying
food stamps and were denied medical
benefits to legal immigrants well he's
tying the bill that denied them the
facilities trying to connect correct
with it with such righteousnesses
ability signed that the Republicans and
Democrats joined in putting through
Congress they I mean why do we have a
world in which we are holding on so
tightly to our little end clave of
wealth we mustn't allow anybody in I you
know I'm a I'm a rich person and I have
you know five hundred feet of beach and
I don't want to let anybody swim on my
beach it's too crowded already there's
seven people on it you know no I think
of a Statue of Liberty you know and and
the words on the Statue of Liberty and
give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
the wretched refuse of your teeming
Shore send these the homeless
tempest-tossed to me I lift my lamp
beside the Golden Door we should take
the Statue of Liberty off her pedestal
and carry her around the country to
California to Texas to Washington DC and
asked what about this and
yes without somehow I'm promising the
fact that the nation has a poll in the
world
on fossil fuels and erratically
competing whereas this 19 to the city
area and in short supply right now it is
no they appear to be encompassed in the
process of learning
we can succeed without some other
economic energy well I I've assumed that
the part of the PC justice movement is
the environmental movement which is
which is very much concerned with it
with it with the use of prints of solar
energy and the book just came out
recently called who owns the Sun and and
and it's about the fact that of course
solar energy doesn't bring profit to
corporations the Sun is too accessible
and too easy and how no I think that has
to be very very important of any
movement am i right I'm thinking it's
time for us to leave this that people
are giving me a hint
yes ok thank you